hello and welcome to engineering tripos
part 2b 4f12 computer vision today we
will be learning about some exciting
recent advances in computer vision
namely fourier feature networks and
neural volume rendering i'm your guest
lecturer matthew johnson and i work at
microsoft
specifically i am part of the team
working to deliver mesh a platform for
human interaction and collaboration in
mixed reality
while mesh is a very complex undertaking
the team i'm on focuses on two things in
particular displaying holograms of
people and things
here you can see three people two of
whom are collaborating via mesh
on the right this photorealistic
representation you see requires
dedicated hardware to provide the
holoportation on the left is a more
idealized avatar for a user who does not
have this hardware ideally we would like
all users to have the option of using a
photorealistic avatar regardless of
their input modality
this is where neural rendering enters
the picture at a high level neural
rendering comes in two flavors the first
is what i call pure neural rendering in
which every pixel is predicted directly
by the neural net such as is the case
with generative adversarial networks or
variational autoencoders
the second is hybrid neural rendering in
which part of an existing graphics
pipeline such as rasterization or volume
rendering is replaced by a neural
component examples here would be neural
radiance fields or neural textures
take a look at this video on the right
what you see here is a rendered
photorealistic representation that was
created without the need for dedicated
hardware for recording and transmission
and it was made possible by the topics
we are going to discuss today in our
lecture
we can use this technology to create
neural avatars like this one or high
quality renderings of physical objects
or locations trained entirely from
photographs no special scanning
equipment required
but i'm getting ahead of myself let's go
back to the beginning
today we will be discussing fourier
feature networks and their many
applications
you're probably wondering what they are
perhaps with some sense of foreboding as
you've noticed by now they have fourier
in the title so that means it's time for
a quick review of part 1b signal and
data analysis
fourier transforms what are they
well they allow us to go from the time
domain into the frequency domain and
inverse fourier transforms allow us to
go from the frequency domain back into
the time domain this is often a very
useful thing to do for example we have
here a signal that's made up of several
sinusoids in the time domain it's quite
complex lots of samples etc in the
frequency domain however it's quite
simple very few values needed to
represent that whole signal and so even
just for compression fourier transforms
would be quite useful
so how does this work
well in the frequency domain we describe
several basis functions which we
linearly combined to reconstruct the
original signal so here we have one
coming in at zero hertz so the dc
component this essentially just moves
the function up or down
then
at one hertz we have a sinusoid that's
the the first term from the function
and that gets us a good ways of the way
there to you know representing this
signal we go to two hertz for the second
sinusoid we end up now with something
that's getting quite close to the signal
and then finally at five hertz we can
add in the cosine wave and we get more
or less of accurate reconstruction of
the original signal
but i mean come on for a liv hundreds of
years ago it's old and busted we want to
do something exciting and new like
modeling 1d signals with neural nets
surely that's a thing that we can do at
neural nets or universal function
approximators after all
however it ends up that it's not as
simple as that so if you just take an
mlp or multi-layer perceptron and just
throw it at the problem you'll not get
great results as you can notice here
you know we can go in with 64 hidden
units and you know do very poorly we go
all the way up to 1024 hidden units and
still not do particularly well if we add
layers we do a little better
but still not as well as you'd expect
so
why
why is this why is it that neural nets
can't
model
these functions as well as we can using
kind of more traditional fourier
analysis well let's take a look at
what's happening under the hood
so we see here an animation of the
training process of that first network
that i mentioned the one with one layer
and 64 channels
and you can kind of see how it's trying
to solve this problem so on the left we
see the activations of the top 16
hidden layers
and
those activations being multiplied
against the slopes and biases assigned
to them in the output layer
and those are going to be combined
together linearly to produce the
reconstruction that you see on the right
and you can kind of see how it's solving
the problem so it's pulling down things
on the left side it's pulling them up on
the right side trying to get that really
sharp angle
and then in the middle it's having some
difficulty with the squiggles but it's
it's be able to produce something like i
think one two three four five six unique
kind of line segments
from this kind of linear combination of
lines
but you also can see why adding more
channels doesn't help
all it can do is work with what it's
given which is this input which is just
a value ranging from 0 to 2 and and
split it into regions and assign those
regions slopes and then combine those
regions together to try to reconstruct
the original signal so here we have the
same thing again but now for the four
layer 64 channel mlp and we can see
immediately that it does much better
why is that so ultimately has to do with
what it has to work with so it's able to
now use multiple different layers to get
much nicer more complex signals in that
final layer to use to reconstruct the
original signal so you can see over here
on the left some of the hidden
activations look almost identical to the
signal that we're trying to reconstruct
and that's purely a result of being able
to combine together the results of
multiple different layers essentially
taking lines and segments
much like we had you know for the
reconstruction of the signal in the
previous case but then using that as the
input to the next round to get more and
more detail what we've seen here is that
the network has
found a selection of hidden activations
that more or less reproduce the original
signal it's linearly combined them
together to produce a pretty good
reconstruction but it's still not great
all right so it's still not having
trouble with that you know kind of high
frequency uh twiddly bit in the middle
and so so why is that well and can we
overcome it somehow
so the key intuition behind fourier
future networks is if fourier features
are useful for this sort of problem why
not make them available to the neural
network so if you think of what's
happening with that four layer mlp that
we were looking at just a moment ago
it's using the first three layers as
kind of a kernel or a featurizer it's
taking the input and it's turning it
into something that it can use to
achieve the task of the final layer
which is the regressor
but in a way
what it's kind of doing is producing the
sorts of wave forms that we would get
from the bases of fourier feature
analysis so what we can do instead is
take the input signal
and essentially project it onto
different kind of sinusoids
of different frequencies
and phases
and
use those values as a way to kind of
expand that one-dimensional input into a
multi-dimensional but that can then be
used by the neural network to
reconstruct the signal
so here's the same visualizations before
but this time with the fourier feature
encoding
and you can see that it immediately is
able to reconstruct the signal
and
the only reason anything is happening at
this point in time is because the
network has been incentivized to find
the least number of activations to
describe the signal via something called
weight decay and the reason i did that
is i wanted to show how the network is
able to actually discover exactly
how to reconstruct the signal
from the input
you know with multiple different
activations in this case and then just
linear linearly combine them to get the
uh a perfect reconstruction
and this is kind of what we would expect
it's a bit of a contrived example right
we know that this signal is made up of
these uh frequencies that's because
that's how we constructed it so let's
try to look at something perhaps a bit
less contrived a bit more difficult
let's look at modeling images
okay so now we move from 1d signals to
2d signals or images what happens when
we try to predict the value of a pixel
from its location in the image using a
neural net
time for another quick review of signal
and data analysis
just as in 1d signal analysis we can use
a fourier transform to move from the
time domain into the frequency domain we
can do the same thing in the space
domain we can use a 2d fourier transform
to move from signals in space like this
image of a cat to a frequency
representation like the one on the left
in this animation we can see how we can
reconstruct a 2d image via a linear
combination of sinusoidal gratings these
oriented patterns at different
frequencies each correspond to a range
of 2d locations in the frequency image
we saw on the previous slide as
indicated by the graph title
as the animation progresses and we add
more and more gradings together
slowly but surely the cat emerges
let's try to do this task using a
multi-layer perceptron we want to
predict red green blue color values from
the pixel location our training data is
a sub-sampled version of the image where
we sample every other pixel we will
evaluate our network on the full
resolution image no holding back this
time we're going to give it a four layer
neural map with 256 channels in each
hidden layer and see how it does
so here we see an animation of the
network training over time and you'll
see kind of the step of training and the
psnr peak signal to noise ratio which is
a measure of how well you reconstruct an
original signal and we can see that
it's not doing great in fact it's kind
of not doing great in the same way that
it wasn't able to handle 1d signals so
we see here that it's breaking up the
input image into multiple different
linear regions
and then assigning those regions of
color
that's an approximation of what that
region would be in the original image in
its attempt to sort of reconstruct the
image and so you can kind of see
the shape
and rough texture of the original but
it's definitely not a very good
reconstruction
we see here an animation of the mlp
training on the cat image
on the left are the activations of the
64 channels right before the output
these are the images that are combined
into the reconstruction on the right
you can see how different activations
are in charge of different polygonal
regions of the image assigning them a
color to be combined into the final
result
unsurprisingly given the title of the
lecture the solution we're going to use
is a fourier feature network in this
case instead of one that takes a single
input and has a single output we have
two inputs in this case the uv or
normalized image position of a pixel and
the output is red green blue values that
are going to represent the color at that
pixel and in for both u and v we're
going to do the same cosine sine kind of
multi-frequency trick in order to kind
of capture multiple different
frequencies and the idea here is that
we're going to try to do the exact same
thing that we were doing with the 2d
fourier transform we're able to have
different you know patterns that are
being learned and combined by the neural
net to then allow us to better
reconstruct the original image
here is the same network but this time
given access to fourier features the
difference in quality is immediately
apparent instead of splitting up the
image into different regions almost
every activation has access to the full
pattern of the cat
that leaves this layer to simply assign
colors to different regions of that
image to produce the final result
creating a series of hidden layer
activations that were called the pop art
movement
of course it's able to handle not just
cats and it's able to handle any number
of different objects as you can see here
in each case the fourier feature network
is able to achieve a much higher
accuracy than we see from the mlp
i know what you're thinking
there's a pattern here i bet 3d is next
and you'd be right but first we need to
take a slight detour to discuss volume
rendering a technique for rendering 2d
images of 3d scenes that many of you may
not be familiar with but which is
essential for understanding what follows
let's begin with a quick review of the
material from earlier in this course
these equations should be very familiar
to you now the camera matrix c projects
3d points xyz into 2d uv coordinates in
the image plane
we can see this happening here in the
animation first the object is rotated by
r and then translated by t
via the world to camera matrix then the
camera projects the object onto the
image plane represented here by ray
shooting from points on the object
through the image plane and into the
camera origin
what happens if we invert this process
the result is raycasting a technique
used by many rendering pipelines to
create images from 3d geometry
first
the camera is rotated and translated by
the camera to world matrix the inverse
of the world to camera matrix
we then shoot rays out from the camera
and into the scene and intersect them
with geometry and lighting to determine
the values of the pixels
these rays start at the camera location
which is the result of multiplying the
camera to world matrix at the origin we
find their direction by unprojecting the
uv pixel locations using the inverse of
the camera matrix and subtracting the
camera origin
we can then march forward along this ray
using a single scalar value t
this brings us to radiance fields there
is a lot here to take in so we will take
it slowly
a radiance field is a function that maps
the space in this case the cartesian xyz
space into color and opacity
we can use this radiance field to render
objects via volumetric ray casting
the key equation is the one in the top
right which determines the color values
of array r by integrating over the
radians field along the ray from the
near plane t of n to the far plane t of
f
there are three components to this
integral t of t which keeps track of how
solid the stuff in front of the current
position is sigma of r of t which is the
opacity from the radians field that is
how solid this position is and then
finally c of r of t what this position
looks like
recall from the previous slide that r of
t is a function that takes a scalar
value t indicating distance along array
r
and returns an xyz position in space
naturally we will need a discrete
approximation of this integral which we
see below
the graph in the bottom left shows you
the values of big t and sigma over the
course of an example ray
note how the rate passes through two
objects
indicated by the two peaks in the blue
function
however the value of t goes from one as
it passes through empty space to zero
once it hits the peak of the first
object as a result the pixels from the
second object contribute almost nothing
to the final values of the sum
if the first object was less opaque then
the value of t would drop more slowly
and thus allow more of the object behind
to show through
let's look at all of that in a more
visual way
in this animation we track the path of
array from the camera origin through the
image plane and off into space
once we hit the bounds of the rendering
volume we start collecting samples from
the near plane to the far plane
rays from all the other cameras are
being cast as well collecting samples of
their own
we then sum all of these samples
together weighted by the opacity and t
values resulting in the final pixel
value
from a machine learning perspective
what's exciting about this process is
that it is entirely differentiable from
the first ray being shot out to the
final image render meaning that we can
use it as a way to train neural nets
we can also use it to train other
representations as well the most common
discrete representation of 3d volumes is
the voxel representation so called due
to the way in which it divides 3d space
up into little cubes called volumetric
pixels or voxels in this animation on
the right we can see what happens as we
increase the number of voxels we use to
represent a 3d object as number of
voxels increases we can produce more and
more fatal representations of the object
at the cost of exponentially more
storage space
let's look at how volumetric ray casting
can be used to create a voxel
representation
these are training videos one frame
every 50 steps of gradient descent for
the first 10 000 steps
on the left you have a lego model and on
the right something we've used in the
past few slides a bust of antennas which
you may already have seen in person next
door at the fence
here are two more objects on the left is
a bronze statue of a rooster from benin
and on the right is
well me
note that for these sequences we have
odd artifacts and details being
plastered up against the sides of the
rendering cube this is because this
voxel representation has no way to
encode view dependent effects and thus
must sneak them into bits of the volume
we could of course address the issue we
just saw by increasing the input
dimensionality of the radiance field to
include the view direction but this
would run smack into the problem of
using voxels
let's think for a moment about an entry
which is an extrapolation of a binary
tree to end space
the common ones have names a quad tree
for two dimensions an octree for three
dimensions so named for the number of
children so quadri has four children an
octree has eight children
and we use them to model how we divide
higher dimensional spaces into
hypercubes so
in the case of a quad tree or modeling
pixels
in the case of an octree are modeling
voxels
we can compute the number of nodes in an
n-space binary tree by the formula shown
here and you can immediately see the
problem as the dimensionality of the
space increases the number of nodes
needed at a specific depth increases
exponentially
at an exponential rate
we can remove the empty voxels but
that is those that don't contain
anything but but it still is going to
increase at an exponential rate so we
need to have some other kind of solution
for modeling radiance fields
and here we are we will now discuss how
we can use the volumetric ray casting
we've just seen to train neural nets for
use in neural volume rendering we will
then see how using fourier features
helps us again to achieve much better
results in this new task
here you can see the results of training
in mlp on the four 3d data sets from
earlier i'll describe them now in a bit
more detail
the antennas and lego datasets consist
of 120 images and hemisphere around the
object all synthetically rendered the
lego dataset uses material-based
rendering whereas antennas is rendered
opengl
the benin dataset consists of 84
photographs taken free style around the
object by a photographer and finally the
matthew dataset consists of 36
photographs around the subject taken
simultaneously by a capture rig
you probably noticed that the result
from mlp is quite blurry
this is because again all the network
has to work with are the raw x y and z
values and thus it must carve up the
space into polyhedrons and assign them
colors as you can see on the left
each of these carvings of the space are
then added together to create the blurry
representation on the right
no surprises here we will add in the
same encodings as before but this time
in three dimensions and see how the
network is able to use them to better
model the radiance field
here is the training sequence for the
fourier feature network
as we saw in the 2d case each neuron in
the final layer has access to the full
pattern of the object and can assign
colors to either the positive or
negative image of it that then get
painted together into the final result
that we see on the right
here are comparison orbits of the
trained mlp and fourier feature networks
the top row in these visualizations is
the nearest training image to the camera
position in the orbit to give a sense of
how well the network is able to
extrapolate from data
i've added two more data sets to the
ones we've seen so far a rubik's cube to
show that even for very simple geometry
the mlp still struggles to achieve a
good result and a wooden dinosaur
skeleton
let's zoom in on the dinosaur dataset
here we have a close-up of the fourier
feature network model results on the
t-rex data set which was created using
ray tracing and physically based
rendering this means that materials will
interact with light in different ways
the first thing that stands out is the
specularity and shadows on the red plate
and the bones which are missing from the
render on the left another obvious
difference is the controller cable which
was a structure too fine for the neural
network to recreate still this is a
definite improvement over the result
from the mlp
so we've already seen how fourier
feature networks can make a huge
difference in modeling radiance fields
but there's more we can do here to
improve quality the first trick is
obvious add more layers make the network
deeper
next we can look at different sampling
approaches
in the video on the right we see a
visualization of the standard sampling
strategy for volume rendering regular
samples along the ray bounded by a
rendering volume in this case a cube
since our networks can model continuous
positions in the space there's no reason
we can't perturb these samples randomly
during training to allow the network to
model more of the space a technique
called stratified sampling
the next sampling trick is to use the
opacity predicted by a pre-trained model
to bias our sampling towards the parts
of the space that are likely to contain
solid stuff
as you can see here
this allows us to learn fine detail on
the object
finally we can add in the view direction
since the network is a fixed size and
deals with continuous values we incur
very little extra cost for doing so
at last we arrive at the model for
neural radiance fields or nerf
in many ways this is the exact same
model we've been using all throughout
this lecture but there's some key
differences
first we've added a lot of layers the
main section is now kind of eight layers
deep at that depth you start getting
some signal degradation uh just from the
number of layers and so we've added a
skip connection that essentially takes
the input encoded values and inserts
them part way through the network in
this case at the fifth layer we then
take the outputs of this main section
and we combine them with the encoded
view direction values so this is
essentially the ray direction that the
position is on
we then run those through two more
layers to get the color but importantly
not the opacity
we want to predict the opacity just from
the position values alone this will
encourage kind of a positional
consistency otherwise the network could
kind of plaster bits the model all over
the space to satisfy the constraints for
the different camera views much like we
saw on the voxel representation earlier
we can see here how the changes we've
made to the network structure and
sampling strategy have paid off in a big
way first and foremost the rendered
picture on the left is sharp and clear
and the textures on the various objects
are correct the extra layers have helped
us in this regard adding in view
dependence also gives us all of the
specularity and shadow effects we were
missing before
finally the fine sampling gives us the
controller cable
here we can see the results of training
a nerf model on the antennas and lego
datasets
note the fidelity and consistency of the
model despite the network having never
seen these poses
also note the view dependent effects on
the right like the specularity on the
tractor treads
here we see how nerf handles photographs
in the wild the lighting conditions
blurring from camera focus and the
specularity of the material cause some
of these images to be blurred or have
divergent lighting flares
the accuracy of the depth however is
quite good and there are angles from
which it does an excellent job of
reconstructing the statue
finally we come to me
nerf is equally able to model organic
objects handling things like subsurface
scattering on my skin or incredibly thin
filaments like my hair very well however
it can only interpolate between the
camera poses which are made available to
it in this case there were no cameras
looking at the back of my head or below
my lower torso and so the material there
is largely hallucinated still it does a
pretty good job overall
thank you for your attention i hope you
find the material as exciting and
interesting as i do i encourage you to
continue your learning by looking at the
code in the github repo listed here and
also the jupyter notebook
all of the videos and visualizations
you've just seen can be reproduced with
the code you find there and i hope you
find them to be useful learning tools
if you want to read more about the
topics we've discussed please take a
look at the materials made available by
the authors of fourier features that
networks learn high frequency functions
in low dimensional domains and nerf
representing scenes as neural radiance
fields for view synthesis you can also
look at the work we've done at microsoft
in this area by reading fast nerf high
fidelity neural rendering at 200 fps in
which we show how to dramatically speed
up these techniques in order to use them
in mixed reality finally if you like the
3d videos and animations be sure to
check out scene pick an open source tool
for microsoft for creating interactive
3d visualizations that run right in your
browser thank you again and i'll see you
later this week at the q a session